Потік туристів у "Межигір’я" впродовж останніх 5 років
після втечі Януковича не вщухає. Щороку туристи
залишають тут приблизно 36 мільйонів гривень.
Платять вони не державі.
Фактично це пожертви на утримання усього цього майна.
Збирають їх громадські активісти, які
опікуються "Межигір’ям" ще з часів Майдану.
Колишня резиденція Януковича може давати
значно більший прибуток, вважають представники
київської фірми "Cкомпані", які за результатами конкурсу
обрані його новими управителями.
- Є приблизні підрахунки,
спираючись навіть на слова того ж коменданта,
який озвучив цифру в 36 мільйонів гривень на рік,
що вони заробляють… Я думаю, що ця цифра занижена.
Ми зустрічаємося з представниками "Cкомпані"
за 29 кілометрів від самого "Межигір’я".
Бізнесмени кажуть, що заходити офіційно в "Межигір’я"
вони не можуть, поки не підписані усі документи з АРМА.
Це Агенція з розшуку й менеджменту активів корупціонерів.
Межигір’я планується зробити
максимально доступним місцем, де можна відпочивати цілий день.
Для цього збираються запровадити регулярні автобусні маршрути з Києва.
- Ми хочемо знизити ціни за рахунок більшої кількості відвідувачів.
Вони можуть культурно провести час,
відпочити на пляжі, відвідати батутне містечко,
відпочити в дубовому гаю на чудових диванчиках.
За умовами конкурсу, управитель має заробляти
на утримання об’єкта в належному стані.
Якщо прибутки будуть перевищувати витрати, то
80% різниці йде в держбюджет, а 20% - фірмі.
Бізнесмени зацікавлені отримати зиск від усього:
починаючи від ретро-автомобілів Януковича,
які можна здавати в оренду,
і закінчуючи "Хонкою", спортзалом, тенісним кортом і спа-салоном,
які наразі закриті для масового туризму.
- Було б дуже добре зробити там якийсь
готельний комплекс зі спа, фітнесом.
Тобто щоб це приносило гарні кошти.
Бізнесмени зізнаються, що ретельно об’єкти "Межигір’я" ще не вивчали:
були там лише як туристи.
Але бачать тут у майбутньому більше фуд-кортів, навіть ресторанів.
Візитівкою резиденції має стати українська кухня.
Ось цей дебаркадер "Галеон" переможці конкурсу
хочуть перетворити на прибутковий ресторан,
хоча всередині вони ще не були та детально ситуацію не вивчали.
Цей будиночок на воді був створений
виключно для потреб Януковича та його друзів.
Приблизно тридцятьох, якщо порахувати стільці й диванчики.
Виходячи з умов АРМА, що нічого не можна змінювати,
перебудовувати і псувати майно, гості ресторану
мають сидіти всі разом за одним столом.
Рестораторам треба якось розміститися на цій маленькій кухні,
яка пристосована більше для розігріву та зберігання їжі.
Але бізнесменів ці моменти наразі не дуже турбують.
Їхнє перше завдання - оформити договори з тими,
хто вже надає платні послуги в "Межигір’ї", зокрема - з кафешками.
- Ми хочемо перепідписати договори відкрито,
щоб платилися податки і була чітко зрозуміла біла бухгалтерія.
"Біла" бухгалтерія, офіційний комерційний чи то соціальний бізнес -
це те, що в "Межигір’ї" поки було в принципі неможливо.
Тут 90 різних об’єктів, які будувалися не як підприємства,
але могли б ними стати.
Теплиці, де вирощували еко-овочі для Януковича,
могли б продавати їх офіційно супермаркетам.
Гольф-поле могло б стати офіційним клубом,
де б тренувалися спортсмени.
На думку активістів, це реально, якщо
надати "Межигір’ю" статус, приміром, національного парку.
Цього вони вимагають від держави з 2015 року
і навіть створили громадську організацію з такою назвою.
І саме цю ідею - розвивати "Межигір’я" не як бізнес-проект,
а як історико-культурний заповідник, -
пропонували тендерному комітету АРМА,
коли разом зі "Скомпані" і ще одним ФОПом
брали участь у конкурсі на управління.
Результатами конкурсу тут дуже обурені і вже звернулися до суду.
- Нашим зверненням до суду ми вимагаємо і чекаємо
на рішення суду про відміну цього тендерного рішення про переможця.
Ми розуміємо те, що однозначно є складова корупції
по цьому  тендерному комітету і рішенню.
Активісти не виключають, що за фірмою "Скомпані "
можуть стояти люди Януковича.
Принаймні директор Олексій Вороненко - політолог за фахом -
колись працював із  Костянтином Бондаренком,
якого називали політологом Януковича,
і з колишнім регіоналом із харківського табору Януковича Євгеном Мураєвим.
- Я  підтверджую, що працював один рік у Євгена Мураєва.
До Януковича взагалі ніяких відношень не маю,
не знайомий ні з ним, ні з його оточенням.
АРМА заявляє, що не має повноважень
перевіряти доброчесність переможців конкурсу.
Але щоб з’ясувати це, вже надіслала матеріали конкурсу в ГПУ, НАБУ і ДБР.
В АРМА зізнаються, що вже трохи втомилися
від дискусій навколо "Межигір’я".
Кажуть, що громадські активісти мали всі шанси на перемогу,
якби створили фірму і подавалися від неї.
Адже АРМА проводила конкурс не лише на управління "Межигір’ям",
а й усіма активами підконтрольної Януковичу фірми "Танталіт",
які під контроль АРМА передав суд.
Тут і статутний капітал у розмірі 150 мільйонів гривень,
і інша власність, дані про яку містяться в матеріалах,
які Генпрокуратура поки не передала АРМА.
- У трьох томах, близько 1000 сторінок,
аудиторський висновок про  діяльність ТОВ "Танталіт".
У цьому аудиторському висновку є всі дані про активи,
починаючи від "Межигір’я", закінчуючи, можливо, тими об’єктами,
що ми здивуємося, що ТОВ "Танталіт" володіє.
Про те, що конкурс стосувався не лише "Межигір’я",
а й усіх активів "Танталіту", за словами Дениса Тарахкотелика,
АРМА не поінформувала активістів.
Та й борються вони лише за "Межигір’я".
- Вони маніпулюють, розумієте?
Квартира Януковича на Оболоні - вона ж була в цьому кейсі, як вони кажуть.
Вони ж її вивели. Вони ж могли зробити,
вивести "Межигір’я" з цього кейсу
і собі проводьте на ці 100% "Танталіта".
Ми ж не знаємо навіть, про що мова йде.
Активісти звернулися до президента Зеленського.
Вони вважають, що вирішити складне питання "Межигір’я"
можна ухваленням закону або про його спеціальний статус,
або про його націоналізацію.
Адже до 2007 року резиденція в "Межигір’ї" була в державній,
а не у приватній власності Януковича й фірми "Танталіт".
Цікаво, що Верховній Раді теж саме пропонує і АРМА.
- У нас є ще 3 пленарні тижні… будь ласка , шановні,
внесіть законопроект про націоналізацію,
прийміть рішення, президент підпише, опублікує,
і забирайте.
Найпростіший спосіб.
Страуси Януковича останнім часом не в дуже доброму настрої.
Принаймні, цей страус на прізвисько Жора
на прохання доглядальника вже не хоче танцювати.
- Давай потанцюємо, давай?
Націоналізація для Жори та його друзів - собак Януковича -
була б справжнім порятунком.
Тварини юридично взагалі не існують,
а відтак не можуть бути передані нікому
в управління, щоб за ними доглядали.
Їх годування, обслуговування коштує понад 1,5 мільйона гривень щоквартально,
і фірма "Скомпані" вже зараз не дуже впевнена,
що хоче взяти на себе такі додаткові зобов’язання.